[Music]
bt responds to little nazix releasing a
diss track after the network left the
rapper off the nominee list for this
year's bet awards we finally gave y'all
something it's only a week yeah little
naj channels his frustrations the best
way he knows how releasing a song on
twitter tuesday
[Music]
[Music]
in a now deleted tweet little nod
sarcastically writes thank you bet
awards and outstanding zero nominations
again black excellence naturally bt
cleared the air on what little nas
believes was a major snub in a statement
released to e.t bt praises the rapper
who was nominated for best new artist in
2020 and called little nas a highlight
of their show when he lit up the stage
in 2021 with this fiery performance
performance is going to be the best one
no offense to all the other performers
and who can forget his 2019 performance
taking the stage with billy ray cyrus
for his hit single old town road
[Music]
bt wrote in part we proudly showcased
his extraordinary talent and creativity
on the show twice and added quote no one
cheered louder that night than b-e-t
plus the network says nominations are
decided by a voting academy of esteemed
media professionals none of which are
bec employees
[Music]
a place little gnaw spared better than
2022 grammys where he was nominated in
five categories it wouldn't mean the
world i mean honestly
and i know it's cliche to say but like
i'm thankful for the awards but you know
at the end of the day i'm i'm just happy
to be here he went home empty-handed but
seemed grateful for the love telling
fans the strikeout only makes him want
to go even harder
oh
my beautiful
it's beautiful it's beautiful
congratulations thank you congrats thank
you
it's already grabbed me nominated and
since giving birth to his debut album he
told et he's already cooking up more
magic all right last thing what does it
mean you just came off maternity leave
what is that it's go ahead i'm gonna let
you there's another bunny in the oven so
there's another one in the oven it's
coming i'm announcing right now guys yes
[Music]
you